so this is very interesting I teased
this earlier in the show Donald Trump's
daughter-in-law
Lara Trump was interviewed on Fox News
this week and she was actually asked
about the health concerns surrounding
Donald Trump after his completely
outrageous behavior during the West
Point commencement speech that he gave
over the weekend now I want to be like
crystal clear what's important about
this is not so much what Lara Trump says
obviously Lara Trump says Trump's fine
right that's not surprising we wouldn't
expect her to say anything other than
that what matters here is that the story
actually made it onto Fox News back in
2016 in all of those bogus Hillary
Clinton has Parkinson's type stories
Hillary's unhealthy Hillary's dying
stuff even now stories about Joe Biden
and we see Tucker Carlson and Sean
Hannity sort of allude to Joe Biden's
cognitive state we have not seen any
mentions of Donald Trump's obviously odd
behavior that could be related to health
we already discussed on the Monday show
Trump struggling to drink a glass of
water and you know sort of having to use
his other his left hand to help himself
drink water at West Point we saw the
video of Trump almost being helped down
a ramp by a military officer looking
incredibly ginger and unstable and frail
raised a whole new host of questions
about Trump's health so here is Fox
anchor Martha McCallum actually asking
Lera Trump about health concerns take a
look through the hubbub over this well I
think it's sort of sad that nobody
focused on what the president actually
said at his address there at West Point
it was such a message of unity and
togetherness and strength of America and
how proud he was of all of those
graduates there it was the whole thing
yeah it was so nice instead people
Martha of course focus on the way he
walks down a ramp this was a ramp that
was you know had no steps no handrail
the President had on leather shoes of
course he's going to take his time and
go down and I got it nobody wants to
fall down in front of cameras no I get
it but just just to ask you you know
straight out is there anything about the
president's health that the America
public doesn't no no absolutely not it's
just fodder for for the critics out
there to attack us so of course it's not
surprising that Lara Trump says
everything's completely fine and there's
nothing to see here
about Donald Trump's health that's not
really why I'm talking about this the
point is the fact that this was even on
Fox News is huge because it means that
the issue of trumps health is now on the
radar of some of these right-wing Trump
sycophants who primarily get their news
from Fox News and wouldn't ordinarily
hear about this story so understand that
were it not for segments like this
there's a huge portion of the country
that wouldn't even know anything about
Donald Trump's confused speech and
limited reading ability visible
confusion the often dilated pupils while
sweating his strange stance and all of
these other signs that have been topics
of concern around the country for years
at this point in time so I'm not really
praising Fox News and any kind of
broader way but it's a good thing that
the story actually made it on the air
because this is likely the first time
that a ton of Trump astrak-- snooze
Watchers are even hearing about the fact
that there are health questions
surrounding Donald Trump now also just
kind of in the vein of fact-checking
remember that initially Donald Trump
explained the reason that he walked down
the ramp so slowly and gingerly was that
the ramp was slippery Donald Trump
tweeted over the weekend quote the ramp
that I descended after my West Point
commencement speech was very long and
steep had no handrail and most
importantly was very slippery the last
thing I was going to do is fall for the
fake news to have fun with final ten
feet I ran down to level ground momentum
so that was quickly identified as bogus
because people just looked at weather
reports and video of the event it had
been completely dry and sunny all day so
the ramp was not slippery notice that
now there's a new explanation from lera
Trump which is that there was no
handrail and there were no steps and
that Trump was wearing leather
shoes the no steps thing is extra funny
because by definition ramps don't have
steps it's like well he would have gone
down the ramp faster if it had steps
well then it wouldn't be a ramp would it
it would be stairs so ultimately what do
we make of the ramp incident I don't
know
here is a side-by-side video for our
television audience of Joe Biden and
Donald Trump both walking on ramps the
level of mobility is clearly very
different does this mean anything other
than Trump is getting older maybe not
the point is we don't know it could be a
sign of a stroke it could be a sign of
really anything we just don't know and
importantly none of this is anything to
make fun of Donald Trump is 74 years old
he's obese it's not shocking that he
would have some mobility issues but the
point is the constant dishonesty and
attacking others never answering
questions straight up and increasingly
deceptive feeling statements and actions
when it comes to his health which we'll
talk about later including the
completely bogus thing from 2019
remember where he was rushed to Walter
Reed Medical Center and we were told you
know what he just had a few free hours
he decided to get a jump on that 20/20
physical it wasn't believable and now
even some Republican groups are making
this a focus let's talk about that next